[Music]
welcome all right and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 80 and it's another
glorious Sunday we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got tell-tell studio closure
PlayStation classic backward
compatibility the future of Sony hands
and to discuss so we're gonna get right
into it so we want to show we still
might get them later on today
but of course you know we still have our
most technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also
sastra darkness mister offline profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing good fantastic well I had a crazy
week at work I don't get a lot of gaming
it what I finally sat down yesterday
first thing I did was get that platinum
no I need receipts I need to go get that
done you know dived headfirst into Tomb
Raider so just how you feeling are you
digging the tomb Raider's beautiful like
summer some of the criticism that I've
heard about it's not quite at that
uncharted level polished and it's true
like in certain things like facial
animation and stuff like that but the
environment art the world and the detail
in that world it is amazing they just
need a little bit a little bit more to
really get them there and then the
storytelling has never been on par with
like with things like Uncharted stuff
like that like cuz if you know what it
is they need to focus more like for me I
think great stories come from the
interactions of characters I mean
Uncharted has always had that never we
care about the story about Uncharted but
the relationships and it's the same for
Tomb Raider they try to make this this
close relationship with Jonah that
doesn't really hit the way it should and
then beyond that it's always this end of
the world apocalypse type story this he
doesn't lend itself to like small
moments really so but beyond that the
gameplay in all of that game it's
fantastic beautiful so I'm going keep
playing that and then I'm gonna playing
some switch that's the only thing up it
really had the opportunity to play go
clean that up
the Capcom bundle the beat him up
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you really realize that when you have it
for free right program these games in
such a way will you just keep feeding
those quarters in no so cheap towards yo
is ridiculous yeah I was the Lord of
Commerce was the bed of his convictions
nothing must earn a premium experience
and is the leader of the fraud yesterday
man I was so happy to be so wrong I was
so happy to be so wrong because I really
wanted this kid Anthony Joshua shoutout
to the champ
um one champ you know is out there
Wilde is the champ the WBC the prestige
champ he is the other for the collectors
he's like David Daniels getting Infinity
Gauntlet he's like you try and get that
last ring Wow buddy has something to say
about that um let me tell you man I
thought the boogie man a perfecting oh
but definitely
handle his business um I thought that he
would drag it out he will muddy it out
he would work him real good
no in the first round he started no boy
the old Russian bear the old Russian
bear was in there he was it was an even
fight going to the seventh round for me
yep go home and what what I what I saw
that Anthony did that was very
intelligent was he took away Povetkin
his jab no once he took away his jab
perfectin became predictable and he was
leaping in with left hooks and right
hands crosses and stuff like that so he
was able to time him properly and when
he got tired because he's a smaller man
trying to work his way in Anthony didn't
lean his body on him to make him tired
he made him tired by trying to work in
to get the work done when he pulled back
that lazy
left jab mm-hmm this boy exploded over
the high with a right hand that was shot
out of a cannon like you have to see a
car I saw I saw a replay slow-mo of some
like very extensive jab into like a
power of real time because real time is
where you really see it grow fast it was
so fast and turned the tide of the fight
in two seconds no it was like I got you
now it exploded on his head like like a
grenade like he couldn't believe what he
was on top of him and he did what he's
supposed to do to finish him
that's what I was hoping the last game
would it did with Canelo because every
time Canelo made a mistake I lost him
didn't make him pay
he spent a jab and he was trying to win
on point this young man this is his 22nd
pro fight I think with 21 knockouts man
he is such a polished or let me ask you
a quick question cuz y'all know you
never seen combat talk I've been
King on this in India so my things like
is this do like it doesn't want to have
the other battle yes yeah so like this
kid has two bells of one Bell
no he has four oh yeah okay so day this
is not the next thing like why are we
not getting the reason why they not
fight now is because the snake oil
salesman at home did want to risk that
payday first they can build the fight
they kept trying to put people in front
of Wilder so you can lose no no need the
boogie man of the east wild knocked him
out after precarious fight you know
where he was in danger to dance though
this is the boogie man of the West and
AJ took out the boogie man so boo buddy
mance is off the board but alone comes a
spider in Tyson Fury Tyson Fury has set
the fight with Wilder in December 1st
one thing he dies no fury about it I'm
pretty sure he you know his coke self is
about it
wild and this guy will get it on I don't
think they don't get it on April they
will get it on sometime next year
Oh as what I was playing ok I was
playing my destiny yesterday um and then
you know I was just like yo let's get it
on because almost halfway sleepy and I
was saying I had to watch the fight and
my son was dying to see it and I put it
on and I put it on my TV game this
generation like it might be definitive
game this generation before for visuals
and control what about that seamless
transition between you know I'm saying
that the regular in game play and then
right into cinematic that's in real-time
[Music]
yeah you're right it's real tough nose
like sovereign are you still on the
Panasonic Ely all you know
sometimes okay si no no I'm just asking
because I wanted to know what that
because you know that plan was crazy you
know the crazy thing is I have the elite
put to the side I'm trying to find a
home for it right right get rid of it
like that because I have such reverence
for that TV but it's like if you know
everything is so far surpassed it now
but that I mean yeah the black levels on
ITV already you know what I will ask you
to do please um put it on it I mean I
just want to know what it looks like on
that tape because that's all I can think
about my team is like man that's the
first thing I popped in my head I wonder
what this is you know I might consider
doing that cuz I just I cannot bear
giving it to somebody who doesn't
respect we have no we lowered Cognito
right now realness in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so um
yeah for me it's just destiny man it's a
full-time job
I mean it just is what it is we've been
leveling crazy I think I'm like 550
something right now oh we started the
raid we actually started to raise we did
I got what shout out to UM ln8 crude is
you know you know I'm saying we got the
other one yeah is it repro dough
zero everybody knows you know but um
yeah man like it was cool we're gonna
set up a spire start with them to try to
get that sleeper simulant catalyst so we
gonna go back to that rate that you
attack already did cuz I actually I can
do I'm saying and I want to get that
sleep I'm really honest okay I would
give imma give you up look around for AJ
at this moment and I'm calling the big
floor or that situation
[Music]
I got a call on my cell for spider-man
yes I got for police to myself again
forgetting extra sensitive with my clan
mate hardcore he is rough he's the
sandpaper dude you know sometimes you
don't want sandpaper on your skin didn't
fill the sample so you know I was extra
salty with it you know you gotta take
everybody's personality how that's my
clan mate one for real he's always been
there for me so what you know destiny's
good fight with your friends you fight
with your friend every moment you don't
say comes out I want to salute Lorex bar
we have kind of got into a little bit
and it has it just has something to do
more so with them just getting a group
together at the last minute and I did
something for sinister I just threw out
like a LMG for something they do I don't
know how to do that plan well how they
do the what is it the escalation
protocol instance any like look you just
do it so I wasn't even think I just put
it out you know it sucked like clear
don't get you know say so we gotta bump
heads with salute low Xbox that's my
dude you don't say sandpaper verse
sandpaper at that moment we both wanted
my opinion is good it was a jump but it
all comes down to this is when this is
good everybody was getting grades
everybody wants to not get left out of
activities and that's what is that
camaraderie so salute to the clan we got
to our senpai moments no saying I'm
gonna reach out to the Lord's we go do
this thing it's we've had max capacity
on the plane
salute to everybody actually shouted low
Megatron he's like jump jump in real
quick and I'm saying here listen the
flashpoint he's like I got to get down
with this Ray stuff I'm hearing y'all
talkin excited you know whatever we're
gonna have to make some audits
oh yeah based on activity level it's
just to the point now it's gotten so
active if you're not active
unfortunately we're gonna have to make
some cuts but
what's gonna happen is you're a gay was
so bad it really still holds you play go
to taro Bhutto an outside ring action I
mean I think I think Tecmo World
Wrestling was more polished but yeah I
mean for a first first attempt playing
there Oh Jim
like with that old album cover lovely
gazes big smiles I was doing that and um
go to caveman 2 games just popping like
I love the story mode he doing even
China
and like they doing it how's the switch
1 in terms of bugs I'm here and let
people have him I'm not having I'm not
having you try to play 2k you have to
login today so you cannot play it really
offline you know I'm saying for the most
part I mean the my player mode because I
didn't goes to the server and keep
checking and save your stuff to there
you know database or whatever so um yeah
like it's late like your face you anime
go to graphics is late I'm like yo like
you in China you're trying to work your
way I guess you didn't make the NBA
Draft it's it's a full slate like sports
games right now to camera is a full
fledge cinematic story straight up huh
like everything like yo a teenager that
about then you go out there and like the
Chinese coach he not really respecting
you and then I feel like it's funny like
I did what happens like you trying to
get to the NBA man are you trying to
shine and I guess your man so that you
grew up with like he's on some like he
made it to the end but he's tall for the
Lakers well abroad on them so they like
they do like an exhibition game with
like the best Chinese team which what
you guys make and then you fight you
face against them and your man it's like
they put this fictional character on the
Lakers to give you a back story with
this guy he made it
you didn't and like you like y'all I'm
trying to get oh that's the same exact
joint that they did with Madden yes yes
don't say so it's like yo man is really
really cool I love what they do in the
store like I care for normally most
you know what they got you mean um the
Falcon he's one of the people that Scott
and then for the two K veterans like if
you've played past two K my players
stories you always have like this
rivalry got his face yes they have they
face the stories right I'm really
enjoying it you know I'm saying and
doing you my prayer so that's that's
pretty much been it for me on that I'm
say so we got to get to this polio so
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
all the recent announcement at the of
the latest Nintendo Direct how did this
affect your outlook on the future of the
Nintendo switch moving forward the
winners winners at 47 percent been the
first ever
il people tie the same old ports and bad
online service there are great games
announced in switch future is bright
group the Nintendo switch is clearly the
most polarizing tablet that encapsulates
the switch perfectly but yo salute also
you know say to the third place who
actually baited a tie the shallows would
cover that last place messing things up
at 6% was that I don't care no LeBeau
announcements it was
okay what do we think about this I think
the polls have spoken
[Laughter]
I was laughing I could not believe this
was going on but shout out to everybody
you know they said Oh Charlotte punching
the chance up yeah everybody who voted
you know I'm saying loud will be coming
in at the end of the show so we got
these topics man soap and this Lee you
know this was gonna be for Lord addict
you know I mean he set this off so we've
got you know obviously you know what's
going on and he has a different
perspective on a lot of things and this
one was a surprise you know we
definitely the news broke you know as
far as what's going on with telltale you
know the layoffs and you know actually
they're just just like a full studio
closure you know and um that you know
that the press release went out you know
basically they said it's incredible
difficult year for Telltale's they work
to set the company on a new course
unfortunately they ran out of time
trying to get there they release some of
their best content this year and
received a tremendous amount of positive
feedback but ultimately that did not
translate to sales with a heavy heart we
watch our friends leave today and
basically spread out to other parts of
the industry with their brand of
storytelling now what I thought also was
interesting there was also um you know
people complaining there was some rumors
about um conditions you know say as far
as what's going on in you know work
schedule and so forth and the challenges
of making these games that they had and
um the last thing is I want to shout out
Emily
buckshot she's basically she's on
Twitter and she's a former telltale
employee and she had some interesting
things to say you know about the
crunching and what's going on and um
yeah
so I don't know if you guys got a chance
to see this but the PR guys stuff - yeah
I did see the PR stuff - yeah sorry I
don't know his name off our fan I was
just reading on the thread and he said
that he wasn't privy to a lot of
information and stuff was held back from
him as far as you know him being because
he's the sole PR person that was bored
so I guess the word wasn't really good
enough because when you have a one-man
ship you know you can't really you know
sail all over the place and those games
are great but like upper management was
privy to what was happening and middle
and lower management were not right so
that created this whole this whole
surprising thing at the end where nobody
it came out of nowhere right so let's
just clarify what Emily said so pretty
much she's lucky basically cuz everybody
was like it would shock them no one
expected it to happen it was some little
Inklings but no one really said oh my
god we were not privy yes so pretty much
what she said you know basically around
250 people are jobless not the 225
definition was reported she said they
didn't get any type of severance their
health care only lasts for one more week
you know many former employees were
contract they can't get unemployment
they talked about the lost army in the
cost of living in the Bay Area in San
Francisco people living paycheck to
paycheck you know and there's also
people who started at Telltale's
recently as a week ago some of them had
kids they were from cross country they
relocated so basically she just cleaned
and put out like if there's any position
in the industry you know - please go
share them - telltale jobs and you know
a lot of people here so let me let me
get this to the lord anchor first man
cuz obviously you know me and you've
gone at it offline or certain things
whatever gonna add it but we have this
discussion you know so like what are you
were you what is your feeling on this
whole thing were you shocked and like
what ultimately you know do you think
happens now like where's your whole
pulse on this thing I'm gonna preface
this by saying two things two qualifiers
one what I'm about to say I'm saving for
my my volcano hot take for Monday
you're not gonna get the volcano hot
sauce you're getting the Taco Bell fire
sauce give us give us your what what I'm
gonna talk about I'm not talking about
the developers themselves who were ended
up working for telltale none of this is
their fault mm-hmm I have no remorse no
no no going down this route Wow because
this is a prime example of a studio
cashing out rather than cashing in where
they had their success in 2012 and they
won Game of the Year for Walking Dead
Season 1 yes and they did nothing no
fine did nothing because I want you to
be very clear on your position like what
they did was they they said okay from
now on the games we are making it is
telltale Walking Dead Season 1 but with
a different franchise yeah they did this
whole helix structure they didn't change
it it's the same type of game in every
single time to milk it rather than
involve it this is the nursery cashing
out cash again they cashed out they said
we have a lot of goodwill people trust
us were like we're the prime of the
industry right now but instead of us
developing ourselves and making
ourselves better innovate and make sure
the studio itself can survive going home
okay okay when they did is they cashed
out and said no we're just gonna make
the same game over and over and over
again nobody cares anymore
so you basically attribute it that's
that's been the the people who detract
on telltale you know one of them
issues tend to be like that engine right
because we've seen other people mimic
the formula invested they were just
talking about going to unity right right
it's like it's been six years just now
deciding to go to unity right and I will
I will give you this thing because you
do make a valid point on another level
too as far as the size that you know it
just seems so sudden so again I don't
know you know like they would do you you
would assume with all the licenses they
get remember they had game with the
wrong
guardians of the galaxy Batman they were
coming out with stranger things you know
they backs on you know strange thing I
get it I totally I don't believe them no
this was oh we didn't know oh yeah sorry
guys it all happened I don't believe
them and I still think there's more
that's gonna come out I'm waiting for
the Jason's prize okay if it comes out
that there was funny mismanagement
let me shout out about Lord brainable in
the chat saloon here we have dinner last
night has to do right there he said this
is an industry-wide problem designers
developers and other creative
professionals are sucked dry it's about
out with no regard to their humanity so
he's saying that this is actually a big
issue that's continuing going on in
industry now what are you saying like
Lord Artus an anchorman as far as the
whole I know right I feel about the
human side I know how you feel about the
country but what about the human side
what about you know little people I'm
saying like you know these people
of course those you can of course those
people it's not their fault they were
working for the Machine they're working
for corporate this is how things work
right the corporate III
I live in North Carolina where
right-to-work state no unions here like
inches they're gonna chew you up spit
you out from that side and I'm coming
from the side there we meet unions to
help protect our people these people got
the door the next day and I'm coming
you're coming from the standpoint of
that side right and I'm gonna come from
the standpoint of this side this side is
I just finished that game and I thought
they won't arise I was like but
apparently you're in the minority in
this case cuz no one's buying it I think
um I think Microsoft could have saved
them no they could have saved them as
far as they could have broken a deal or
myself to put all those games aside game
past wonderful you're not thinking about
though that is a lot of money yeah
there's a lot of money start investing
in them and not just looking at it from
the Stalder glasses though we're
retooling I'm looking at it by what
Phyllis said that how he wants to put to
struggle driven games all right kula did
fit that also not keeping track of
youtube exists there's a great little uh
I'll pull this up for you guys
dan Stapleton over at IG I've had a
great take on this what do you think
like he yeah
no no this is this is just by his
impressions on it I think this is
exactly dead-on this is what his little
tweet thread sentencing telltale was an
interesting developer it's breakout hit
Walking Dead Season one with something
unlike anything we'd seen before
you know it's maturity and emotion was
almost unprecedented that was amazing
but everything after that was something
we'd seen before in a new set of
clothing
it's a problem I think is its failure to
come up with new gameplay to complement
the storytelling
isn't that a pared back gameplay in
favor of pure story which led me to
wonder why I was playing this instead of
just watching no that's a fair excuse
case off perfectly I mean you talk about
the saturation you talk about eight okay
the engine being a joke the saturation
of the product right if but if you and
that's exactly what I think the problem
was if you look at like if something
like until dawn if you look at even
Detroit become human life is strange my
impression is that those games have
mechanics with at which at the very
least give you more to give the
impression of more agency within that
story within that world right they we're
walking dead it's still you can have
some diverging paths but you ultimately
always come back to the same ending
right there was no real
choose-your-own-adventure moment it just
gave you the impression that it was
doing that so that's that's the next
part of this day of simple the quarry
says after a couple of games the helix
structure became obvious matter what you
did no matter who you are who remember
what the effect the effects only
mattered for a short time before you're
brought back to a common point the
illusion of choice was shattered and
nothing mattered anymore you know what I
got it I gotta keep it a buck
I've played 90 percent of their games
and I will say that is very true
initially how they started was very
ambitious and that you could affect the
endings characters would die you they
especially with the Walking Dead they
really attend especially with the us the
character that I used to take care of
Clementine he was the white guy and
besides Lee they had a different story
so I'm very I was very excited to see
but when they started to regurgitate
someone to say informal or angry is
right what dance table tennis saying is
that you made choices that would affect
short-term things small things but the
game would get back in power I would say
this cuz I'm have to agree with Chief
Tommy here maybe that crunch time stuff
actually
made them scale back things that they
were ambitious with and instead of
shooting two to three endings they had
the formulated to get right back to that
one concise and then that they was able
to do to move on to the next project
engine so like they like anger said like
they they made the decision to crunch
the to roll these out and you know put
these on like on an assembly line and
just keep rolling them out rather than
evolve the formula which one was that
upper management was that middle
management I mean you know whatever the
decision made that affected the company
moving forward like I'm sorry sorry
gotta say something real quick that your
your hands elshout did him in a chat and
he listens to us at work every Sunday
missile ooh he's making a good point
that we're all not seeing and I didn't
think about this and he's right he's
saying yeah he said but there's people
that that are not well versed on
controlling video games and like playing
these styles of games because it's
simple and engaging my wife is a big
example and that's true because I've so
people are Walking Dead games and no the
telltale games have never played and I
just hand them controller and all they
got to worry about is like one button
maybe press up deaf direct for a QTE and
they got into it I've showed this game
to non-gamers you know I say assume I'm
Randi or executor but sue brand a lot of
people my boy Paul I'd a really damn
casually you know I'm saying like Evan
blinking game and they got into this and
I would see people just sit and watch me
you know I mean so it did have a market
maybe it it war itself thin with the
hardcore game but once we figured out
the overall mechanics and way this thing
go but it is interesting to to Lauren's
point is that it didn't translate into
sales anymore we have to be honest with
that you know saying like it still
didn't translate into sales anymore and
is that mismanagement
what is that right like oh you know the
point where I knew there was a problem
mm-hmm when the first part when you
noticed what everyone kept asking for
words give us wolf among us season to
finish wiring dead give us those two
things that's what people want they
didn't listen they said now here's some
Batman
galaxy so that's fine that's okay okay
you follow that money that's okay but
when they announced last year we're
gonna do wolf among us season two we're
gonna finish Walking Dead I knew there
was a problem because you fix out until
yours you don't go back you don't go
back to my fans want unless you're
desperate mmm oh you don't know you're
right no no no you're right because
destiny too had to be humbled when they
tried it I got it numbers went to the
toilet everybody a man Bush it was in
the bushes and then what did they have
to do community summit for all the
community leaders over there gets to
with the call they're able to pull off
one another that is that's the big point
would you look at studios and you look
at developers what they will do is that
you sometimes you have like a rare like
you know out one out of a million out of
the blue
always every once in while you have
someone who actually says we're not
gonna do these random projects I wasn't
gonna use Bethesda in this case I was
gonna use CD Projekt RED know everything
but this problem is a little more
because they're now moved into a
publishing role they do what people want
but they also do projects they want to
do right it's a it's it's not really
good for like I say more in terms of
like CD Projekt RED they're doing
something you have you have developers
who will do what people want and that's
all they do and that's a one out of a
million kinds of thing but when you have
you have other situations you'll have a
developer who
who they don't listen to the fans cuz
they think may know better little men
will crash and burn and then they come
back they come crawling back just like
your box under an Old Crow but he wants
to clarify his statement he said he
didn't say he said telltale had a very
toxic environment and engine caused a
lot of issues crunch time is normal and
interesting but obviously it was really
bad at telltale studio so that's his
position poor Tom good Sami was about to
say something real quick back to Joe
Hansel's point about a about these game
thing it's our games the simplicity of
these games really do appeal to the more
casual gamers the thing about is with
casual gamers they're also not willing
to sort of sift through all the jank
eNOS and craziness like for me
anybody any like with my nephews and my
niece that they're very you know the
attention span is very short if
something they're playing is not working
properly they're gone they're gone and
that goes back and that goes back to the
engine and the engine on every single
platform they put it on had issues so at
some point even the people who like the
casual gate casualness with the game
playing the mechanics of it if they
can't get past the technical ask the
hiccups of it right no it's not gonna
appeal to them and they're gonna turn it
off quickly so I think that's another
issue that happened with that and it
goes back to what anchor said from the
beginning eyes from the very top down
there it almost seems like they they
were apathetic to improving the formula
for the player it just it feels like
they just cared about making money in
the moment and nothing else they didn't
bother to try to do anything you guys
have known me I have talked about this
for years you guys I want you to try
something they have different well
everything yeah I remember trying right
and they wouldn't do it you've been I
have to give you credit when you have
been very consistent from the very even
when they were in there hey you were
like you know I'm not feeling them using
the same formula over and over again
engine you had issues with and you're
just like hey do something different and
I get that you know saying and it's just
one of those things that's gonna get
into my point
quick it's sad for me oh man like bro
like I love that game I'll never forget
walking dead the first season you know
and I remember watching the videos of
grown people crying at the end and you
know if you haven't played it you know
with the character leave so it's just
like that
really I was like yo Nate they were
doing something at that time no one were
doing it was just like okay that is the
[Laughter]
brand I must be undead those two those
two or and Megatron those three were on
my heel cuz that was right before this
that's it look for destiny to comes out
I'm actually gonna play other games
I'm gonna finish mad games I'm gonna try
to win them up and telltale came to
rescue you got telltale games
a stoolie finish so shout out to them
one at game school or your
it just really hit me this one and just
one of those things that you know they
will always stay with a shining star at
that time when it when you drop those
joint and no I guess like like I said
the truth is gonna have to come I was
gonna have to be like one of those yeah
II know you find out anything else about
like two years two years lady a may not
way find out about till then examine
against hope here but I still I still
think there's an opportunity for
Microsoft Studios on I think I just
think you need to do a number of things
right you need to improve that engine
you need to improve the storytelling you
need to make it a true
choose-your-own-adventure you need to
look it's like until dawn and Detroit
become human to evolve that that's the
thing we keep looking to tell toe cause
we got these nostalgic glasses we
remember them for what they did for
Walking Dead and wolf among us we
remember them for that but they're dead
they are they are mentally gone the we
were thinking from them as a 2012 studio
where they migrated point the other
people came behind Detroit and the other
game onto dawn and they took what they
did and just you know add it on to it
know there's people who Luke tell tell
out of the water one here's one came on
thinking out that her life where they
said we're taking the whole idea of
where choices Matt right before taking
that idea I don't know what they called
the the ghost game no I know there's a
game that is universally beloved came
out in the last few years that took over
that mantle we're telling tale that
formula the helix engine gone no one
cares about that anymore
a game where choices mattered mean game
play was deep witcher 3
how is better to be really you play with
your three yeah yeah actual thing though
end of end of Act one you have to
character the bloody baron go through
that thing and this is how big of a
difference it is that thing has like six
different drastically different endings
mmm that changed the rest of the story
right that's a that's something that
telltale never did bring it into late
some like life is strange
something like until dawn and in Detroit
and until dawn there's a little break
off of the same engine in the same
format let's keep it in the same format
because you're gonna talk about an
action-adventure game with multiple
endings different Junction imparts
sorrow yeah it's not fair because it's
six years to try to do something
different to become Olympics winner the
interaction with the game is totally
different was talking about a game that
can appeal to people like hardcore
gamers as well as casual you the point
when you look at it though is what were
the strengths of telltale it was choice
right that was the biggest thing that
everybody agreed this is what everybody
can get on with storyline
I don't think it was ever choice to me
it was it was story it was interaction
to me relationships conveyed in those
stories not the choice because very
quickly you realize the choice wasn't
really there you were gonna come to one
conclusion right but
very quickly you realize you don't know
that the choice is more about the
weather the weight of the choice right
that is these were deep hard questions
you had to answer the same thing which
are three and the issue in the thing is
storytelling in that aspect the where
the flag was with Walking Dead Season
one has already moved on no agreed what
I'm saying is the fairer comparison
would be like life is strange a
comparison would be like Detroit becomes
human like where they've advanced this
where the branching yeah it's like
Detroit is like the next level of it you
know I mean like it was but I would
agree with anchor in that he is right
that they the mantle was lost what I'm
saying cuz after Wow
yeah if you still have that same engine
and you still not improving upon it and
like he said to keep what he said they
just now was thinking about going to
unity reason why brought this up is that
the reason why I brought it up was
because Microsoft coming into self save
telltale it's not worth it people if
they were to go in poach everybody and
then come back in and said oh yeah we're
gonna do the same we're basically make a
I don't know short story studio TF God
cover for your neck you said my
girlfriend a plane in which two three
but she played that one right you know
that would be good if let's say a studio
and I'm not gonna say just Microsoft cuz
we got to stop looking for a big bank to
buy a little bit always use because
they're all are gonna do is tournament
what what I would like to say is you
know other Studios purchase time ago
Sony has a great pedigree as well maybe
a Nintendo needs to diversify their
portfolio and get these guys but um to
put in like the game pass type of thing
they could do a Halo or
Telltale's type of game they can do all
types of games like gears a world type
of game that way Sony can do an
uncharted game that type of way to to
cater to the people that like lore
Cognito said that don't play video games
but complain that type of game and I
understand that because I need those
easy achievements I'm not even talking
about it from from like a delivery stamp
like a game pass like as a delivery
thing for me is like well if you do
something episodically right you're
spending less money on it over all right
you create an entire season of something
and then you see if it sticks
in game you have a monthly and you don't
have to worry about that influx of money
constantly coming it's there right so
you can take that risk on one season of
something and see how it goes the other
thing Kittichai said these telltale
games are garbage
even so he said well what off about back
so why don't Sony come in and buy a save
a damn studio right now the last thing
you've got going in the chat right now
it's very very conflicted or what what
you have unfortunately think at this
point would be the actual talent that is
John coach poached you know I'm saying
especially I would say on Microsoft side
because we know the single-player game
experiences you know Sovs love it's not
really strength this gen so maybe they
can get that talent put them right
without distinguish on single play
experience is only on sony second one is
god of war but their first one addict
actually think that spider-man wasn't
gonna sell as well as God you know God
of War was such a phenomenon spider-man
though through an Indian as I thought
more about it all I thought about is
like you know us we or most of us here
on MCU fans so it's like we're like yo
the MCU is on fire right now
then happen a great spider-man game and
I'm thinking about the promotion and
then Sony in the market and I'm sitting
there you know we had we had a lot of
people on with this out to be money you
know we zone brat and we had this
conversation and Eric Jackson as well
and as you talk as I talk more about it
as is
Spidey's coming but you know came on I
they had been a third-party game by some
meteor developer some movie tie-in yeah
I would be like destroy it the moment
they said insomniac first party Sony oh
my god it's gonna kill it just is what
it does no it was sovereign the moment
that I got to eat three and I saw the
game look exactly like cuz I said when
it showed it I was like oh that's a lot
of so nothing
yes oh oh oh no I played it I said oh
god was in bushes touched it I said oh
god a war is in the bushes when I sit
down on the floor and I saw was like 50
people in the crowd with cars moving in
HDR and lightening I'm like they're
doing this for PC no no brother has a
Playstation bother with this hoodie they
tossed the idea go to back yourself a
spider-man at the bus that whole deal
but getting spider-man exclusive that
was because of the whole Civil War the
spider-man the MCU
I know we kind of track with that but
you're saluting all the telltale guys
hope he's gotten people up I heard
people job offers have come going out so
hopefully these people find homes yeah
man we definitely want them once the
best today good people lost their jobs
we want this time to get back out in the
[Music]
Lord King what is going on classic
streets which Sony was going on oh they
saw you know making that breath yo we
don't care about backup at well we care
about that bread dough hey see you okay
we do we could get a Raspberry Pi and
shrink it down and make it look like
how about we ship it out with no power
call it let's get to the beat of what
was it that so basically it's the Sony
PlayStation classic yes is the
overpriced version for old games yo they
have the nerve to say $100
so Lisa we're going for the gusto
because we feel that I jumping jack
flash is better and these are twenty
games to be determined but I'm trying to
figure out like its distant version of
back pad are they gonna start releasing
a version to version 3 with 20 different
other games or the cash grab what's up
yeah let me jump in because um you know
obviously the announcement we heard you
know the classic and then they had a lot
of those games a lot of rich a lot of
good games you know and of course right
now I believe the UM near Sony's like
they have 20 right now they're gonna be
available and the only thing that
surprised me and I want to bring this to
solve too is that they they've made the
announcement that just like Nintendo
with the UM NES classic having 30 games
and the Sun s only having all just
twenty okay they're not planning to add
any more games like that's it it's a one
and done here's your 20 and I wanted to
bring that back to you guys specially
came because I know you are the vintage
guy you are the guy that goes out buys
these systems I think that's that's
where I struggle see this is where I'll
show ya like I'm cool with all the back
panel so but I've I struggle with this
because it's like little it's just a
time piece for these games you know I
don't want to attack like this is just
Sony like this NES classic is the same
way like you don't feel a way that
they're not gonna support this thing you
buy there's just d20 and that's it you
locked in forever
and anchor hit that because home polls
but the only reason why I'm gonna let
him go first and attack it is because
again I'm bias right like Lord cog
needle said this idiot might run out and
get it help with those numbers with
those nintendo's I got both of them
right they came out so I didn't know and
I brought them for my kids so when when
I purchased it I purchased four let's go
to some curious about Psalm though like
so did you buy like the NES classic I
bought the SNES classic for um for my
niece and nephew okay did not buy it for
your personal self even either one okay
now when there about now the PlayStation
classic and he's got that you know too
many controllers taking three like like
does that excite you like how do you
feel about doesn't it doesn't excite me
like in theory I mean theory I'm not
bothered by it because I get it it's a
crazy like is the cash grab just like
those were right and play not nostalgia
the thing about it what bothers me is
this blatant ripoff and said that's just
crazy like it's easy to figure out
anything else you couldn't figure out
anything else to do and I realize if you
look at Sony like after spider-man they
don't have any exclusives like this this
is their exclusive for the rest of the
year after us right
try to sell something right but I to me
if this is gonna be one of those one and
done things and obviously people will
hack it and you'll be able to get more
games on there because they've done it
with both Nintendo systems when it
assuming that the innards are anything
remotely similar and somebody like it
mom fact it doesn't make any sense not
to allow more of this stuff on there
because then you say okay what are you
planning to do with the rest of that
your library at some point are you gonna
give me are you are you gonna give me
what you think what I think you should
give me which is a classic bundle of
money of games on your ps4
that you you know that you can enjoy the
games there y-you have to give me a
piece of hardware that I have to
purchase these games don't hold up as
well I don't want to look at all ugly
polygons of those games like I'd much
rather play final fight beautiful big
sprites then somebody might wanna play
the final phase it's a subjective thing
but I don't think ps1 games hold up
nearly as well in this one point I will
say I will give out to Neo Geo gold
system the biggest props because that
system came out it's a portable system
that you'll also play in the house all
right so the same exact thing that you
got right there is the same exact thing
that you know play in the house but also
the games that come on the system is
retro games but you can also get booster
games packs to put in to add two
additional to those games so you start
off with the initial 30 and then you get
another booster pack with another 40 or
30 games on it and then yeah of course
you pay for but there's no option in
doing so with these little owns you know
many bustle systems right oh let me get
the chat is let me give an angry shout
out there god is on fire it's only faze
be like 500 plus games from two previous
generation for no charge with backward
compatibility or xbox has got it but you
say we don't want that but a hundred
dollars for twenty ps1 games
he said the PlayStation classic power
cable is probably Milly rocking for the
same thing with the new Nintendo 3ds
because I've never bored about it yeah
so this is all the classics the classics
had them but okay two versions of it
didn't have AC power cord they had
alright so let's get inked in it X be
quiet what do you feel about one classic
systems and then honestly the
announcement of the playstation closet
[Applause]
this is one of those things where I was
like ok I looked it I looked at when
Nintendo did it
right I was like you know what okay fine
the people have that nostalgia if they
want to throw away their money that's up
to them that's totally fine mm-hmm and I
think the with Nintendo they never said
Oh old games are bad we don't care about
old games because they have a very rich
history of supporting their old toys so
thank you sure those old titles come out
they always make sure you could play
those old games they may charge you a
$60 they're gonna make sure you can
chance play that old game the thing I
run into right a problem is that Sony is
really damn cocky this is some
next-level stuff like listen this is
basically them saying hey we're going to
tell you later man you wanna tell you
Spidey do wanna move we're gonna tell
you we don't want you to play
do you I did afraid you are sorry I got
to cut you for a second addict babe
let's go to how you do everybody God
defend your honor it was coming they
said you was stuck in the continued
aggravate they would get addict you
noticed I just say ultimately what I see
it as is that Nintendo never insulted
people about play at old games but Sony
actually did say this thought for the
next topic please hold it I gotcha
okay cuz this we gonna tie this all in
and and my topic is coming up next is
really gonna flow into the place to
anything and we're backward
compatibility just save that particular
thought cuz I know where you going
questioning you with classic systems and
retro systems like I know you as the
Gamecube do you're that guy right so
nobody most likely come but let's just
say they announced it and you know okay
the same deal no problem let's say those
twenty or thirty games or like the
income and classics of all time and you
to added cuz I know you guys are you kid
you got your gang cute guys you know
[Music]
probably not licensing when it comes to
this one I don't know about this
PlayStation Mini what the Gerber came
here put in there like if they came out
there and they put like you know real
classics in there like right crash team
racing orginal Crash Bandicoot yes viral
yes if they do that mmm as a as a solid
package fine that's all
like Barnum said buddy are easily parted
like go right ahead I will not buy it I
still I wouldn't buy it for a hundred
bucks but less your hundred dollars is a
lot dope yeah those games
I'll go get a PC before I go let's get
addictive because um obviously called
butch girl with the UH with the
classicism and I gotta ask this question
on her channel chuckles II didn't miss
that that was his topic so let's start
with this topic with the arm the
PlayStation classic announced twenty
aims it's kind of locked in to those
twenty and just your feeling about that
first the are you talking about the
PlayStation classic get that I believe I
personally think these classics are
becoming an issue mmm
I feel like these companies rather so
you 20 games for $100 and 20 games for
like $10 each and what do you feel are
you on my side of the fence ways like
there's no more state they tell you that
after that 20 there's no more being
added to that mini console like all you
wanna say it's not a difference with me
with that yeah well I don't really care
too much on that or apportion mm-hm
because for the most part you know
people it would be nice but I think it
would be more hard they don't want this
to be a long-term thing hmm they want
this to be a one and done so they can
sell you classic 2.0 next year for right
there they have five hundred and some
odd games and I think they're gonna go
for the whole Monte on way every year
they're gonna release a new 2.0 I I go
with 20 game I could see them doing a
like an RPG one with different games
I don't think Nintendo I think Sony
we'll do that I think Nintendo goes up
with different hardware like the next
one is gonna be the n64 joint right and
then after that you will get the
Gamecube joint
um and then I maybe they might go back
and do it from the beginning
I think they'll realize how bad which is
weird they will realize how bad
something looks that you release a 2.0
version with 20 different games or 30
different games the following hardware
like I don't get that like what they're
doing is and now they're giving you this
online thing with the NES games and
they're gonna put other stuff that maybe
they would have put on a classic -
pointing or put in a service right right
and still get you to pay for it like
real quick fried because he missed it
these top of the first ones the telltale
closure we kind of hit it in the head
and came inside was kind of like he saw
it coming you know he's not in the party
chat with me you angry all in the party
chat together next bus loud before this
offline and you know he's on the side
offense - hey you know they didn't adapt
you know the engine was old and you know
they kind of just mismanagement and you
know pretty much that he's not surprised
I don't think it was that because if you
look a lot of their games are highly you
know kritis a lot of their games gets a
lot a lot of praise at the end of the
day when you have a complete game that's
driven by narrative focus if they don't
buy that in the first week the game's
probably ruined for a lot of people so
they're not buying it now right uh and
let's be real here twitch kills these
kind of games - yeah watch stream game
where you can stream it for your
audience so that hurts a lot of so
there's a lot of factors that goes into
this you know I've said from the start
that you just I put a tweet out that was
like you know this shows that driven
focus games like if people were like no
that's not true and what's funny is I
put Sony in the title I said unless Sony
makes these kind of games or Bethesda or
CD Projekt RED player games are they're
not dying but they it's a hard it's a
hard it's a hard market to penetrate
without without the big-budget marketing
like I said with the Sony and stuff like
that with the you know these type of
games got a war and it's by them and and
let's be clear all
so it's not just about making him these
games gotta be good these games gotta be
they can't be average you know I'm
saying like they have to book the trend
but are you comparing them to RPGs
though or are you talking about I'm
saying these are driven games in general
you know when it comes to this look at
this game
these games are $25 they they for $25
you couldn't get a better single player
driven story focus and they still
flopped and I think you know me and you
know lore carnita brought up a good
point I think the biggest key points to
why this company failed is because they
oversaturated their own mark and they're
competing with each other later when
you're launching this week this comes
out to weeks this comes out people are
tired of that game play so they stayed
away from it entire and in the last
question on it is um because of what you
say because let me go at Jeff on I'm so
no look I said single place like I said
Sony you like that's what kills me like
when I say single-player driven games
people want to bring up spider-man
people want to bring up God a war people
want to bring up these at the end of the
day it's like I said unless you're not
that oh my god want to keep burning this
why don't we bring up the evil within
evil within to Dishonored Wolfenstein
like these games do well but they don't
do it completely fantastic like these
games when did you see Wolfenstein so
three million in two and two days you
didn't see that did you what about God
you didn't see none of bringing up the
same six games acting like 50 don't flop
every year your stance is that that
those are the anomaly as opposed to the
norm right your your point is that hey
like not all of these single but not
that single player games are dead
but that not all of these single-player
games this particular genre you ask the
brain smoke or you don't bring nothing
at all Sony over there hidden you know
that hitting home runs you know but this
is a hitting this and then you got you
got press CD Projekt RED hitting home
runs like if you do not bring that kind
of quality your game isn't gonna flop
you'll probably make profit a little bit
but you know a lot of these people spend
just about what it costs for the actual
project on marketing itself okay and not
just that he's actually very right about
that specially wouldn't
is that it is it is a hit and miss
problem it every single time it has to
be a game that not only is good because
there's a lot of good but does the games
that come out then don't sell very well
yeah move it around they did not do that
great right that's a phenomena to did
good and it didn't do good well I mean
the games are putting out are good games
that's the thing that's make any sense
like they're great games it's just they
have to work about their marketing and
my even with the marketing problem the
issue also comes up like it has to be a
franchise no wrong Sony games are just
well-made that's what telltale games
fail they were really basic with decent
stories that people like to hear and
watch that's why they were big on twitch
he says slow mo telltale is out of
business because they were mismanage not
some bigger narrative on single-player
games so people are still defending the
fact that once they defending but
they're still trying to say that this is
more of a telltale missing management
issue and the Saudis are the more you
spend on marketing unless you stand and
making profit a lot the chat is split
the track does I think I think more
agree with you then but it is it is a
contentious
as far as the tell-tale situation at the
end of the day it's like I said if you
compare like I'm sure if you went we
don't know the true numbers of these
gangs you just don't but if you've got
their numbers like Bethesda the king of
I'm making single-player games I don't
care I'm continuing on this adage I'm
making an online multiplayer game this
year single playing nine well guess what
their cry for single-player they're
putting microtransactions in why because
the cells of the game aren't gonna be
that great and they know it mm-hmm like
shot a shout - Samko but he's agreement
he said the order 1886 was made
incredibly well single play game and
sold like garbage so say it has to be
has wide appeal like it is like the
reason why that was as much as I hate to
say this and you know people like
because I know the reason I don't want
to say this because people would have
come at me like those CUNY games we're
and then you got like the the one on
Sony does the same thing on steroids I
mean look at spider-man spider-man
unchartered god war they're all
cinematically it driven it's it this is
the reason that they make these game
swords because they own a movie studio
they know how to set these set pieces
they know what appeals to people because
they sell movies for a living they said
the orders are the bushes games as much
as people don't like it
sometimes you if you want to make really
good ones you have to take the
controller away from them for a minute
like you have to get them emotionally
driven into the some of these set pieces
that's and that Sony does you can't do
that but
you know your typical single-player
games like you know a lot of people like
to make fun of their exclusives for that
but it works out for them this was good
I had to get you a ban on that top that
was a hot one man we're gonna move on is
a lot in this going on man we got some
more news you know I'm saying on the
Sony side and there was definitely
another announcement show exactly we get
complaint there we don't get into the no
silly topic so here we go so you know
I'm saying that is our debut I'm a new
server I'm actually a new servers an
existing server they've expanded upon it
and now it looks like not only can you
download those emissions are streaming
but now you can download those classic
games was places to gaemes to your
consoles you got that going on and some
select PlayStation 4 games part of them
is a blood-borne remember one of the
biggest problems that we had with
Playstation now was the streaming aspect
in comparison to like a you know xbox
backward compatibility so now that this
has been announced now here's the caveat
you know I'm saying obviously you know
right now they saying that when you do
that and this I think King will find
very interesting you need to connect
your ps4 system to the internet every
few days to verify your PS now
subscription if you're only playing
downloaded games so I know that's a
point of contention because obviously
King this was kind of what Microsoft had
announced at their you know yadda yadda
yadda you know and then um okay so
pretty much how it will they all PS now
games to support DLC microtransactions
and add-ons they said as well as ps4 Pro
and enhancement subscribers using the
ps4 pro system and then okay if you
already started streaming the game and
locally on your ps4
transfer you're safe from the PS now
cloud to your console with a PS Plus
membership that is sold separate or that
part is separate in either
please pass and now you know so pretty
much that's pretty much the feature
right now so I wanted to bring this to
the laws and I want to attack it from a
different way so we know about the
service right we also know that in the
past
Sony has made statements and anchorman
had brought this up earlier
um saying which have not been in favor
of backward compatibility when he was
announced by marks office allude to the
back compact team what bills still will
those guys the emulation that they got
to do is this is wizardry those guys a
source of as far as I'm sorry but you
know don't win that time when that
announcement was made I was a big kind
of cuckoo for myself at that time our
good friends it's a Darrell Jim Ryan yes
Diggs to say and I pretty much said that
um you know he didn't see what the big
deal was about it you know why would
anyone play these backward compatible
games you know you know it's one of
those things you do it for a while but
when you look at it you know you don't
go back and then here we are so let's
bring this through the table addicts in
the build it occurs in the building
let's start with anchor because he had
actually continued to style woody do you
feel about first of the service I start
with the service worse is it a good
service do you like the service and then
obviously Sony's previous stance on
backward compatibility all right so
first off at least with the terms of the
service I can't use it at least at least
in the current status of the way the way
it's set up with the streaming so I've
never actually bothered I've seen other
people use it though
I I find it funny that a thing that can
max out in terms of streaming only up to
720p is being played on the system that
people tout it as 1080p or nothing I
still find that funny
the thing with backwards compatibility
is just it's so weird to me because
every every generation somebody takes
the backwards compatibility flag it's
not one's like okay we're going to
support this no matter what normally
it's Nintendo but normally somebody else
gets involved to it last generation it
was sony Sony took up the backwards
compatibility mantle they said
we're gonna do that they kind of gave up
about halfway through it said like oh
yeah
new versions of the PlayStation 3 aren't
gonna have a ps2 backwards-compatibility
it's all right people move on mm-hmm now
this duration it's Microsoft and they
it's so weird because this generation
everyone else is eventually picking up
on backwards compatibility but they are
making you pay through the nose to get
it right
it's a Nintendo they're charging you $60
for games that came out last generation
to play them again
developers have now other publishers
have repeatedly put out ports with very
minimal work like Activision and
Ultimate Alliance love stuff like this
he loves just a straight same old same
old thing which again I've been on
record at least a hundred times saying
and I'm not a big fan of a remaster
thing because this is but it's another
way to milk people and this has been a
thing this generation in particular so
we're we're paying again to get games
all over again
Microsoft has said ok backwards
compatibility if you own the game
physically you can play it
Yoda visually you can play it it's not a
problem and they're not making you pay
through the nose to get it which I'm
very I'm very happy with which is very
weird for Microsoft because Microsoft
normally about making you pay that extra
money well that's what happens when you
lose them competition brings out the
best that is true Nintendo Nintendo
Nintendo is doing the same thing except
they're making you pay for it and with
all these releases but then Sony who has
actively gone on record by saying no
backwards compatibility is a feature
nobody really wants like yeah some
people are talking about it but nobody
really cares but then they go and say oh
here's PlayStation now for $20 a month
go play your old games here and not just
that but now they're allowing you to
download them which is great my god any
service allows you to download the games
rather than half the stream that's great
I'm totally fine with that it's looks
they pulled what they were quit
sighs America's soul you gotta have your
system online but this is always online
and then wait a second days exactly we
have daily full circle give you certain
games to download like games that came
out five years ago you can download add
you put that up in their home then those
are sports games mind you which
absolutely makes zero sense in this
world to me but the streaming system it
looks like half fraud or lame okay they
the hypocrisy of from Sony is allowing
you to see the humorous on these dudes
like they are saying alright along with
the little mini and we learned it by
Hansen yeah we will put our little
fingers on it and we gonna give you the
whole thing we have Sony way it charge
you full pay for that I don't make sure
that you have a subscription to us
because if you don't you're not able to
do that but then they say we're not
putting anything behind any pay walls
[Laughter]
what about the pricing for my
understanding that the pricing is a
little different right because we still
have $20 a month opposed to $10 a month
100 games under right it actually works
out cheaper if you buy it for the young
set free time full year for 100 they
said if you thought that that is only a
limited time special that is not what I
get it's only limited but it's still an
option for people if they do it once a
year you could still get it for the year
yes a month or you can get a three month
for the 30 if we're gonna use that logic
that Xbox Live is not $60 a year it's
not a budget here what I'm saying that
smart consumers that knows this is going
to wait for that's not people so you
can't assume that regular people are
smart what I'm saying it's still an
option like it is like if you buy one
year like you know how many times I wait
for Amazon every year to drop Xbox Live
240 like that's not going to be with
everyone
there's still a large amount of people
that do it you will go without live for
a couple of months until it drops warty
I pick up a year let's get you in on
this cuz I'm well I think I need you on
farmers are you know that the whole PS
now you know the streaming service now
able to download to him says you know
how do you feel about that aspect too
it's good I'm one I'm hoping because
they're getting this at the end of the
generation I don't think they would do
this but do you think they would try to
lock all like ps4 games and ps2 games
behind a paywall for ps5 no I think
doing is preparing you for ps5 like
Kingsman saying along ps5 not having any
of this be their legacy back
quote-unquote back compat service
because if you look alright if you look
at what they did that's a mistake I
think so too but I think this is what
they're preparing you for that's
cockiness right there you could play ps4
guys but we need this this this that's
$19.99 a month look at this right and
the downloadable stuff that's on yes now
right now right right let's be clear
that's not really too bad compared the
only thing is that you can download our
games that run natively on a ps4 mmm
their ps4 games and then ps2 games that
have been remastered for ps4 ok there is
no there are no native just ps2 games
that you can just download and play on
your ps4 as a service
what Xbox does with emulation same thing
which is weird also because if you look
at like the Vita the Vita emulated ps1
games on there let me let me defend
someone for a second um which is gonna
be interesting
my question to you guys is what about
the augment cuz obviously we know when
this was announced the Lords of petit at
Microsoft they jumped on Xbox critic out
and they quickly baited it does bit
about back a compatibility I respect I
respect the gangster so you know
basically say you know that you know you
can
all these games and the keyword that
groped the internet was free no an Xbox
mm-hmm and I shout out to a lot of
people into it I some of this narrative
going back and this only fits well like
hey that's not true
those games are not free you have to
have bought those if you own those games
already yeah free but you have to buy
those game so why you're kind of coming
at us what they actually meant was you
can you're what you're doing is you
don't have to pay any extra fee to play
those games again right which is the
word but somebody in the chat put holes
that who's that face 23 all right yes so
you put up PlayStation now is $100 a
year and game pass is one oh don't take
that down I want you to Milly rock with
that holy thing but I want to ask you
this one question sir um what
PlayStation is is spider-man launched in
there was gone because every last one of
you can see they don't have it but you
don't get it right that Microsoft
doesn't have exclusive games which is a
lie and those games are launching in
game pass for free if you have gamepad
and date yeah sony says playstation now
and they're not giving you spider-man
now know what you need to do is go by
spider-man and you could play that later
on PlayStation now if it ever comes out
that PS now is gonna be what we call a
legacy service that's what it's gonna be
you know I'm gonna tell you guys this
forefront it's not at all mmm-hmm here's
the thing I remember reading this
article because I remember because this
is right before I switched colleges
mmm-hmm this is back in 2013
mmm-hmm this is over this was right at
the beginning of this is about like
September October ish right before the
thing came out there was an interview
that was done with Yoshida mm-hmm and
they were talking about the future of
PlayStation
yoshida explicitly states that the
future of PlayStation will not be
limited to hot console hardware oh yeah
they said we're looking at making an app
you can play your PlayStation games on
any system on any platform we're looking
at that that is a possibility for our
future
this is it this is what this future is
what you think what they're gonna do is
they're going to come out this
PlayStation 5 is gonna come out yeah you
got all the new PlayStation 5 games but
you're gonna have the PlayStation 4
PlayStation 3 2 1 all those games gonna
be available on PlayStation now and
eventually at some point we're gonna get
past their past the point for need for
hardware streaming is that powerful
mm-hmm there may not even be a box
anymore
this is Wow things are gonna go crazy
because Microsoft just announced the
system that's gonna be doing it this is
this is par for the course with Sony
like I mean like I gotta give it to them
but but when it comes to stuff like this
they're not they're not the ones to
watch the temperature of the room and
they do it like you know the first and
only with the worst Microsoft did not
look at Microsoft and Sony and Nintendo
when it comes their thing when it comes
to Sony
they are the copycat group like they are
anything anything that comes down
walking on the street that looks
slightly new they're jumping on board
forget it when it turns to order no hey
is the truth I mean Microsoft they do in
the ones to win the week when the week
email while roaster controls were new to
people's iOS is interesting this is new
all right let's be real at the start of
this generation they had the PlayStation
CH called out what is it they're armed
with their version of games were gold
which is on PlayStation Plus they were
snow Microsoft Microsoft had to actually
adopt games ago because they didn't have
anything really in that space to compete
then let's be real at the start of
generation was a lot of room and stuff
like our egg was saying but they had the
e DS one smash guess who followed up
with idea Xbox let's go reason why you
remember the reason why PlayStation Plus
existed bring is because well Microsoft
keen with Xbox lie they were charged we
want some of that subscription money but
we already have our online servers for
free we gotta have something to justify
it
absolutely and what I will give
Microsoft credit in this respect is that
obviously with the PlayStation like
finally those party chat services online
services that 360 had already pioneered
has finally gotten to that system and
kind of got them up to snuff on that but
I heard you say our King I need you on
this as far as on you know the whole
back compact you know is it is it
overrated because
let me stop when you can take your disk
and this blows my mind with my xbox
every time
you could take your disk in you could
put it in and it ones better than it did
when you initially merchants that game
this is this is the PlayStation now is
crap because you're playing it at subpar
levels alright so but now you can
digitally on PA you know on the
PlayStation Network it's the same thing
yeah it's not they're not giving you any
bonus this is a fraud this is a finesse
I think you you wanna know how to be
finesse this is a finesse in progress
alright so I want you to see how to
finesse works they allowing you to think
that you're getting something that
you're really not getting alright if
used to purchase that dish you used to
put that disc inside that system it will
run in the same exact way on the
PlayStation now system you're gonna have
latency you're gonna have subpar
resolution and you have you may have
hiccups that go on because the internet
connection right on the Xbox you will
download you will put that game in it
will run better it will look better and
again you're not gonna have internet
connections because the game is running
natively off the system and it's
upscaling this boost in it alright so
totally different ways and how you're
looking at it the play getting a point
them it's a fitness all right they
telling you that it's it's not for the
price that they're given if they said it
was like Nintendo drink five dollars
five dollars
yes I'm in it but when you start doing
the high price range because you're
milking the people and you're not really
giving them back what is worth because
it's not work because you still need
PlayStation Plus no no no no no they
said you do not need PlayStation Plus to
play PlayStation now games online that
is correct
that's a huge oh it doesn't count
doesn't does anything you can still
download it you can take what
they passed without Xbox Live No
well you need Xbox I to play anything
online you can still download those
games it's the same way as a PlayStation
PlayStation now if you don't have
PlayStation Plus you can still buy games
online and it shows that is true that's
it ten dollars a month more advantage to
different perspectives of it but I think
you're coming up short
with the Pooler games that's a good
argument because you know what the fact
what game pass obviously you're getting
those Microsoft exclusives new
exclusives day and date regards to how
you feel about C at these stated became
but fours is coming you know I'm saying
crack that all that stuff is day and
date on the service and it is yet to be
seeing whether or not PlayStation now is
going to evolve into something like that
as of right now this in God of War 3
anything god of kings
like I said looked at PlayStation now
last night is this the first time I even
bother looking at it I looked at went on
my playstation I looked at it I said
okay hold up now they got fallout 3
fought new vegas fallout 4 I'm like
that's pretty good I'm interested now
let me take a look at this mm-hmm it's
on I'm taking a look at it I'm like wait
a minute I can't I can't download
Fallout New Vegas on here I'm gonna have
to stream it and not just that I'm going
to stream the worst objectively the
worst version of Fallout New Vegas where
the Xbox I was with backup at look at
look at the with fallout 3 and all these
games that bacchum not only they jet
they're giving you these games they're
giving you 4k let me get into my point
because it's like
at the end of the day you know I respect
that service I like that they because I
remember the Gaikai acquisition with
Sony and I was like I don't know they
really bit high on that right and I'm
like okay and as it kinds of comment
comes out you did technical testing it
just wasn't that good
you know I'm Sam now as far as the
bigger picture which is is the backward
compatibility thing is this whole
being overrated you know I'm saying and
I'm gonna say it's not overrated because
if we look just look at something as
simple as this womp the latest NPD we
got Call of Duty its mining warfare to
number eight on NPD that's crazy
these are the people that say no one's
playing all games and you know Cheryl
Jim you know this is a direct shot at
them you know and that's right next to
the god award practice
that's insane so one thing we know
Microsoft been kind of selling the
future on that and I'm kind of on board
with that and some of those guys that do
the emulation and all that because I
think that's amazing and the key
difference from me is again you have
those titles that provide 4k in here did
you see that Red Dead and I just want to
point out something people that say the
backwards compatibility is worthless
it's not doing nothing
Microsoft wouldn't keep putting more
stuff on there they have to be taking
numbers to these do because they don't
you can't do this for free licensing for
these mm-hmm some companies like look at
from the standpoint of call of duty
right they let them put the best Call of
Duty's on xbox if it's clearly not
selling exactly and one thing we learned
a dish out the Liberals still a lot of
this stuff is all marketing and setting
up for next title so look looking for
example game like read that we all know
read there too it's common so what do
they do earlier this year we got that
ready for you you get that base
galvanized right connect to the old
joint you'll because you're the new ones
coming I don't get a chance to it's all
notice we don't know horse gold eggs
it's like you said when it comes look
how many times they've used your older
games as pre-order bonuses yes there's
been times when remember like you get
you would fall out a baker with their
game pass for Odyssey the season pass is
gonna give you a remastered Assassin's
Creed 3 and exactly so it's a perfect
marketing tool and mini height machine
to now get these games that are backward
compatible with these enhancements on
the axe and all these little extra stuff
and you still train your data you know
I'm saying everything that you did on
your 360 is still there with you know
and achievements and online play so I
just thought it was interesting that
they have also now jumped into the mix
you know I'm saying and I'm curious to
see how that goes forward for them with
that's why I think to me it's gonna be
like a like I said like a legacy service
because I don't think the guts of Gaikai
can handle whatever Microsoft is is
looking at to do in terms of like
streaming and stuff a I don't think the
guts of Gaikai can handle that so they
they need to use that for something so
how's it taste like who's playing these
games like that look at MPD brother look
at MPD that all you need to know it was
number eight religiously play that Call
of Duty and they they they hit me up
like yo you got the Call of Duty I'm
like no bruh
get off my line just let you know man
again I think about you know for next
gen we look at what's happening right
now a get grant their fortified right
every time we see this thing now imagine
we don't know we have a theory about
that like I was talking to people about
this like how why this why is Grand
Theft Auto still selling so much mm-hmm
like there's some were copies the people
who are playing games like I know we
think we figured it out because you look
at that
they're bundling that with those shark
cards yes I'm on all Brad yeah they pour
it out yes that's very we were talking
we were talking about that last night we
were like wait a minute you could
there's some of those shark cars it cost
like hundred dollars mm-hmm but on it
with a sixty dollar game like by the
game again is you actually a lot of
people will do it because I have a
couple friends that actually do this all
the time like a new expansion drops or
something like that you know with the
the new equipment and stuff that they
can boss I've seen a lot of my friends
will buy that you know the
the $60 with $100 card then they'll turn
around and sell the card mm-hmm
not the cell the game because you get
too into it you can get an individual
coat so they'll sell the game on like
eBay yeah but we do know it has to be
those of you who are Superman movie or
actually addict let me get you on that
did I get you into what like what is
backpack over I mean it's cool you know
PlayStation is sound sounds I don't know
what they're going to be doing with that
service you know what's funny is what
was the who did that or at last this
might be a little bit off-topic oh yeah
it was the Nintendo thing when they did
the the cloud say thing behind the
pretty last time I remember PlayStation
does the head
it doesn't matter what PlayStation does
you know they're gonna have a giant
following people won't get this just
because you know at the end of the day
if this shows anything competition is
key so you saw this realize that oh we
got a DAT because it lets me where if
Sony is adapting David adapted to a lot
that Microsoft's done this whole
generation this things that they are
adapting to I can guarantee you that
they see this as a threat if they're
adapting to this they see this as a
threat everything is waiting long
waiting so long they want to get the
impression that they don't care but
they're watching it from the very
beginning
absolutely it matters to them it's just
a matter of not giving that impression
outwardly that isn't affected by this so
yo can't do it anymore
no thou it shout out to the chat for
continuing the anchorman versus King
hope that'll all be strong Batman killed
him bro shout out to kryptonite that's
for mo chopper ya know that's a good
show please bring the save energy Lord
in the Sony Love Train announced that
they were finally finally putting the
nail in the coffin officially and the
Vita ending production in Japan which is
the market that has really been
supporting the system up until now ever
since they essentially stopped making
the US version so they indicate when
that which was lost and the anticipation
is a new announcement the PlayStation
swap coming out this no way they
announced as of 2019 they will stop
manufacturing the system and they will
ship out whatever they have left in that
is
so the Vita has been given a time frame
for it yes but another interesting thing
that the hello questions was the
PlayStation Vita ever alive like
[Music]
specifically came out and say we have no
plans for another handheld so my
question to you guys is are they lying
and let me say this with this caveat I
don't think they have plans for a
handheld that has its own library and
its own ecosystem I don't think they're
gonna not that's not happening but I
don't believe there's no there's not
some sort of handheld device coming that
has some sort of interactivity with
either all this PlayStation now back
compat stuff we're talking or even the
PlayStation 5 that I could I don't
believe I could see them doing some kind
of like PlayStation now Vita or
something like that but to be honest
with you man like I think that they
dabbled in the in the handheld market so
long and I think they're done I really
do I don't think they're going I think
as of right now this switch is going to
dominate anything handheld I don't think
they know for a fact they couldn't
compete with the 3ds what makes them
think they can compete with the switch
and the 3ds they're not doing it they're
out of that market my question is this
in that and I agree right with a machine
just like the switch that has its own
software but what about let's say like
everything that's before like they're
able to shrink down schism they able to
shrink down ps4 to the point we're not
going to research and development to
that at all for me it's like one of
those things where I see like you when
you see this which you see the value of
having that ecosystem with you all the
time right but
a better switch I know what you want the
difference is is Nintendo's never you
know went for the for the knock it out
games they've always been in that middle
ground where they can make a game look
pretty if they want but they have a
leftover graphic Sony is not that way
none of their games can can run on a
portable device the ps4 II prior to the
switch that was my favorite handheld
absolutely love I remember a lot of
great games when I'm gonna Grand Theft
Auto and that thing ran flawless
Metal Gear acid I mean I had a ton of
games for that thing I'm even one plate
XCOM on that thing on remember they had
a perfect part of that I mean it was
really cool so you know now with PSP and
now the Vita that's two non successful
endeavors in the portable space so you
know I would love they did in real
handheld I would love them maybe it was
I got the success to other handhelds
that was in the market it was Bauer
yeah they've always lost you Nintendo in
that space that's just fat
and an act has a point they've gone with
power right they've gone with a lot of
things that are appealing to us as
hardcore gamers before whatever reason
it just didn't seem to catch now it's a
SARS question it's like you know do we
see them secretly kind of preparing
something like that to accompany PS 5 I
would love it but I'm agree man I don't
think yeah I think they've been burned
enough you don't know well they've been
burned this is what they know they
why they get to itself
you know why the system's don't sell and
this is direct correlation to why the
playstation system cell they systems
don't sell because their story driven
stuff is done great on a big screen
you can't translate that big screen to
that little screen and think it's gonna
work
Nintendo have mastered that little
screen I think it's short-sighted to
look at the way tech moves and to say
that within the span of a couple of
years we can't be I'm saying
they make games for the the reason why
you are mad at the 3ds and they don't
throw it in the bushes is because
they've mastered that handheld realm not
happy with the SOI said he was something
I want Sony in that space
I want them I'm wit soft like I would
love to be wrong and they come out and
announce Vita 2 or whatever it is to
compete in that space because we all
know grandpa ain't doing everything
right you know they even though they're
successful my whole thing is when I see
the announcement 2019 def date that's
the death date for the Vita no more
manufacturing no more shipping is a dub
right they stopped developing for it
says 2015 they ended production in the
other media so then when they spoke them
spoke to what was this guy um
what's-his-name the president the star
laid him and he said his exact quote is
that for whatever reason and their host
them there were more even more reason if
we were drinking beer but vina just
didn't reach the critical mass with the
audience and thereby the development
community doesn't get behind it and
thereby thereby the audience doesn't
come and it's a quick negative spiral
effect and again I just I just see this
is the second attempt in this space and
I love both handheld I love both and I
thought they were gonna do well it's
just it's just not I just can't see as
much as I want it trust me solve if they
come out and you saw
to Dominus I will bend the knee like I'm
saying don't I have no faith or belief
that it will be an ecosystem unto itself
No so what do you think what an
extension their shrinking appears for
imagine imagine it is not out of the
realm of possibility they didn't in a
couple of years time you can get a
handheld that can run ps4 type games now
imagine you tell me or you can have
Spider Man on-the-go ecosystem you have
already I'm not saying you're making
games what he's talking about in terms
of aesthetics right where it's like okay
I can't play Donkey Kong tropical freeze
nin docked mode it just feels better in
handheld mode okay right I can't play
fallout 4 on a switch because I could
play it on my ex I could play it on
something else because it's just better
for that type of screen it is designed
for that where the I think that's what
we're the real discussion is hardware to
fit your ecosystem they are not willing
to invest in hardware to fit your I
don't care if you I know what you're
saying if we build it it will come no
they're not willing to invest they took
the punch in the face twice right I
gotta get punched in Hawaii but giving
libraries for that I'm not saying for
Microsoft the Microsoft gave me some
portable some important some sort of
portable thing that allowed me to access
the Xbox ecosystem wherever I am
see here's the desert already at the end
of the day they can't compete in that
they just can't like Nintendo I don't
think you realize like how downed a
Nintendo has that market like it's not
even worth trying to compete with it but
the thing is you're not really competing
in that more
yes you are you're improving no people
that would spare you what you're giving
people is an extension of the PS
ecosystem but do you like it weigh
station portable do you think I
understand what's going your that your
nursing staff is not saying like a
traditional handheld about where you can
take max but you can take that same
experience and whether it be screaming
or whatever it is on some type of a
portable device and you have the
PlayStation 4/5 not everybody's gonna do
that happy like you said like like
anchor said like there was talk from
sure you see today this is a possibility
down the line right right the whole app
thing the same thing that Microsoft is
going I've always been up the contention
is there before we get there that is
going to be some sort of middle ground
and so you're talking about a system a
system that actual hardware backwards
they're not going to take resources from
something they can do forward to do that
I just personally yes I understand your
point but I get it in order for them to
do that they have to actually you know
attempt to and I think they're done with
it
I don't even they even started not
supporting the Vita in the like the last
year year and a half it was out like
they they have no it's it's the ps4
started being hot that's their focus the
Vita failed because they stopped
supporting it right but let me let me
jump in out of it way before that let's
do the history right when the PSP
dropped at that time it was mimicking
PlayStation one experiences right they
were they were almost Carbon Copy like
the ridge racers like all that stuff
then the Vita comes out right and that's
pretty much mimicking was it PlayStation
3
I believe you know as far as from from a
hallway stand for a power standpoint and
to me it's like they've always done that
if you're talking about the physical
hardware space now if you're talking
about this other thing see I'm a king if
you're talking hardware I can't see it
they've taken too many elements in it
like like a five percent yeah like some
type of app on the mobile phone and now
I got the Bluetooth PlayStation 4
control like how they jumped into the TV
space right know what that you know your
TV your Sony joint you had that app and
you can now you do your PlayStation now
you're not saying they haven't built a
brand for handhelds like Pokemon they
haven't built something that sells
millions and millions of cars regional
for that platform I agree the problem
but the thing that they've done is
Dave's try to copy their hardware
experiences onto these miniature devices
and sometimes it works and for the most
part it doesn't cause people like you
know whatever that to me you know what
the greatest feature they did and I was
very sad to see the whole thing with
Aveda
the greatest today had was play play I'd
loved remote play I loved the fact that
it wasn't always the legacy with certain
giggling I couldn't do out trying the
control skiing yeah they didn't have
what the switch had with the control
system was the switch has evolved with
the double analogs and all it's it's
like what you guys said there's a market
for consoles and there's a market for a
handheld they try to make a console for
handheld market and nodding and held
market Pokemon is one of the perfect
games you could play on the go on
handheld and that's why it's so I'm
going to right now say that pokemons the
single only reason that the their
handheld market growth over the years
sure there's other games that - that
experience but nine times out of ten
people bought that platform for Pokemon
and then they bought other games
afterwards hmm
listen but I just went elastic I don't
know we've been jumping on saw let's
solve finish his point with what his
vision and what you want and no I just
want you guys to be clear because I said
it from the beginning I just don't get
the impression you guys understand what
I'm saying I want you to I totally do
that I agree with you 100% they're not
gonna
make a handheld that has its own games
they would not do that they wouldn't
that they fail twice in that leave
that's a Nintendo completely so you with
us or not I don't think they did that
with the Vita they always try to down
port stuff to the video the beat of
Sigma the Vita what they messed up with
the Vita was that the Vita came out in
like a weird time span where the ps4
wasn't ready yet and that's something
and they still and they sort of
ham-fisted
like the ps4 and and whatever the what's
a call sort of tacked on to the Vita see
that was the problem Vita came out in a
very weird weird time came like towards
the end the ps3 said I mean I get more
of ps4 I don't think it was bad I think
it was the game's name me a good Vita
game that's so Vitas launched what what
sovereign is saying and let me let me
get this right so the whole digital
library for the PlayStation right that
you have access today right this is what
you're saying right it would be like a
mini ps4 right so this is you that is
also has some functionality what appears
fine whatever that may be question of
course alright so it has access to all
that digital he said terribly what's
tearaway I don't know what that is
caraway well it looks like a bunch of
paper okay all access to all that
PlayStation stuff and whatever limited
stuff to the places far but you want
them not an app you want a physical
hardware that could run it
I think the app is the app is further
down the line I don't know what you want
you want the physical you want them to
make a physical system that can play
that stuff
no no no separates ecosystem that
ecosystem you want oh you are right you
want equal that hard right he's not
coming hmm if putting it that way let's
get the chatters move on cuz Fastback I
understand yourself but Xbox only gaming
mobile streaming apps instead of
handheld system because the apps can
reach more gamers look at fortnight
they've showed they have not shown
anything that they're ready for that
Microsoft has been talking about it like
a year right obviously they have
something differently the PlayStation
now is on ATVs though like when you get
a stony television PlayStation now like
when you when you get that little
Experian failed phone you have
PlayStation now app um they weird bloke
in there Loki treating the they were
Loki treating the Vita after a certain
amount of time like he was the Kinect no
one showed anything and we have a video
game than ounce see right but back in
the day that they would even try
considering their penchant for uh you
know borrowing ideas I don't
done with the portable market they've
done with smaller games with the case
new bone Japan throws at us and he's
basically they just saying from now on
they see every studio must deliver
big-budget cinematic experiences or
they're gone yeah I mean I already
saying stuff I mean it'll be it I would
love them to get back into it but you
know it remains to be seen if they're
gonna do it and he also said our
PlayStation now is no longer on TVs and
I'm saying well then fast back says um
view TVs or Sony TV still have it so I'm
not sure we got your clarity on that as
far as its TVs are doing but I remember
when it did I know
I know they I know things they did they
did pair back on it yeah I think in
PlayStation now not that they've went
this direction starts getting momentum
and Sony BRE invest back into it I think
it might show back up on TVs with this
interaction possible says it sounds like
they need a rise in shipping yeah this
is the bonus time you saw Nintendo
switch on so let me jump in we know who
NES library oh yeah absolutely you know
touch their the emulation you know
there's a minute minor nibble on the
button configuration I guess you can't
configure the way you want as far as you
know because they have like the
japanese-style configuration with
confirmation circle the next kind of
thing yeah yeah you got in universe
that's like a minor nitpick but other
never know you got some minor new pics
dear and I want to shout out Lord Kaiba
too because I have some things to say
now when it comes to game sharing now we
have to admit shout out the Lord addict
when we heard this announcement the way
you know the fact that they are trying
to get into that you know game sharing
at all yes must be doing something on
Xbox and Playstation since the beginning
of the generation
Xbox executives multiple times pretty
much promoting it yeah clearly gotta be
helping the industry so I'm certainly
I'm like exactly so I'm
[Laughter]
Sharon they got it
so everything followed the initial
sharing procedure that I would normally
do with Xbox when we swap the profiles
I'm like okay so join your profile
I see the games that you downloaded from
your each shop right I won't download
those to my system right you download
he's crazy
I'm gonna download all these games I
think I downloaded dead cells okay I'm
in the mix baby I'm ready to pop my
bottle so then I man I cool so I click
on the game so Nintendo told me that's
not no told me that you are not Lord
Khaybar sooo that's what kibosh who's
game so I said oh so cause I don't
stress it just login is me but just let
me know cuz we can't do it at this age I
said no I said no Kyle your meaning to
tell me that this game now that we're
supposed to be digitally sharing I
cannot play the player system it works
it's worse for you cut both of you
because you guys are on ice chips
alright so you could play the game
nothing is why do I have to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
when you started this for a minute I was
like wait game sharing family thing is
we're still arguing and I'm like bro
that means we cannot play let's just say
I didn't buy Mario Cart right and then i
download he board and i down
we can't play like that's literally just
like you do that on the Xbox one oh you
know Fastback this
20 dollars a year you get what you pay
for but you know you know what the real
deal is you do that family plan you know
you would have eight people in your
family this is what this is and then
this is how Nintendo has finessed you
let me tell you exactly what it is they
gave you couch co-op one person at a
time like they took it back to the one
controller watch me play dayz but they
just made it that you could be in the
other side of the earth with their one
controller and not a blade you will not
play something so obvious and yeah I got
to stop calling how many hours I put in
this okay cool
what the hell is in this video if you
want to use your against that old man
make sure that my me bows were let me
find out my memos don't work it was yeah
this is definitely I was disgusted
biggest L took this year
game sharing is nice of the guys is that
game cheering stop calling the game it's
called time sherry I'm not a game I'm
curious about a guy I bought it
that is like okay you've got one
bathroom we have to switch you should be
a bad logs in it freezes up your home I
wanna understand remember it was like I
think was last week I was joking on this
before last week and I said that they
was locking you to a system and if you
did like say would do something you like
trap to that box this is why mm-hmm it's
all leading to one thing is leading to
the next this is the rabbit hole you're
locked into that system so when it's
time you see they can't control your
system right so you can just
automatically boot him out now I'm the
real cop optional the last boss he got
there one more hit
[Laughter]
it definitely is a funny topic or ILP I
have to say we always salute salute
let's get these poles out of here all
right so with the oh okay so with the
recent success of the Nintendo mini
systems and Xbox backward compatibility
title sales is Sony hypocritical for
announcing both the PlayStation classic
PlayStation now download features after
previous statements of game or not
interest a no pure business move Sony is
adapting to the demands of the market be
yes Sony was lying to the profits I
don't care who's playing these ancient
relics anyway those are the judges
please vote when it goes up what lord
anchorman in the building kami you're
holding us down where can the fire
people find you what is going on in the
round
well you guys can find me on anchorman
v2 over on pretty much every platform at
this point yeah multiverse show is gonna
be at 8 o'clock tomorrow you guys can
check out the show I'm gonna go all in
basically giving every little piece of
information make sure that you tune in
you can run back to me and tell me if it
was really hot
[Laughter]
[Music]
most of us back tomorrow I'm sorry miss
now kicking that very APM so we'll be on
no there are 45 minutes show so no three
hours show us 45 minutes please tune in
please
salute that's it bring that energy same
energy over to the Lord shout out to
everybody over there you know saying
Nick the arm the breakfast my man and
then of course faint entertainment the
true little show and of course Sam we
talk tobert the hardest men in show
business on everybody's the James Brown
no dancing they're out of roll masters
of the building bill
salut Edgar before coming to holders now
of course we've got Boyd addict coming
through in the emergency not afraid of
no smoke man ducking slide getting close
to the man has no fear thank you for
coming through brother wake in the fire
[Laughter]
the Lord saw was going on holding the
flag where maybe he was like the warlike
Asur dynamic now hopefully playing some
Tomb Raider this week you can catch me
on the switch I mean Lord kobato playing
up one bathroom y'all one bath
you know you have one bathroom somebody
just got to go in the tub to saw he held
his own now you gotta be doing that yeah
I'll be doing that hopefully and not
working hopefully it'll Cosby I guess I
shot everybody the chat chat was
absolutely lit everybody sit down like
subscribe we already know tick fans in
the building ain't getting here please
subscribe to all the outlets on the
inner circle network we got that popping
and of course on the iron wall pocket as
YouTube got some great content y'all
combat talking make sure that you get to
that page like follow and subscribe I
don't like the numbers did a numbers
dares not equate until what the numbers
just should be so you following the
Instagram if you're following my
thousands of people figure it out it's
not over yet we are gonna put that in
the title and we trying to hopefully
fingers crossed you know put us out in
the universe we hopefully get a Lord map
piscatella out on that show that'd be
great that well button that is one those
numbers come out and it's an official
for the month then we will do that so he
starts to you to bet in the spider-man
but I got the Jurassic world to watch I
mean that spidey sense going on there oh
you get shot two shots a fast me guess
it is ok to check out nlg every Friday
night
that's right tick fan affiliates in the
building fans I gotta get you on the
show too fast mag is long overdue
so yes we are TRC Giannini also
broadcast also the gaming perspective
let's also for guys with corners that's
your Lord Sam hold you got a dick he
said it's not over until you think
they're gonna do this go return those
copies of the game now the questions
people hear how much they got ourselves
first month 3 million - they did 3
million in a so it's close in close I
don't care for win by one your man is
done attic loses
if the bass talk but you don't got it
these are lost get the bees ready I want
no cushioning on your knees I want your
knees bill on the floor oh this is a big
moment right here about to finish
fallout 4 entire every playthrough I'm
about to finish it in about an hour
that's crazy that was nobody kid not
playing anymore until false of these
systems out you are the best with
therefore you don't say she like slept
with combat talking or like this stuff
is updating also shout out to e Barnes's
we got a fire flash please again support
the YouTube channel we still have
original content over there it is
attached need to get those subs up to
about so gotta help us how about taking
you gotta how about the Lords here but
um yeah great debate and everybody if
anybody has anything else left to
address hurry I get to the bathroom
you